[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like that so much anticipation just for
a moment of being annoyed that's all
that was there's nothing great came out
you welcome marvel is joining us on the
podcast on the table today yeah sponsors
he does you having to start with wink
all right okay well this episode is
brought to you by wink
I just got side I'd love a glass of wine
but you know how do is to go shopper one
yourself not knowing what wine is good
what wanted to get what wine will be
good for you specifically
well wink takes care of that guys you
take a little profile quince on your
palate
and they send you wine to your door that
they know you'd like right now go to try
wink that's t ry winc calm there's no
membership fee you guys cancel any month
and they'll go if you a wink talk on try
wing comm slash Jenna Julianne they'll
give you $20 off your first order and
you know what they're gonna cover
shipping as well so really awesome
servers actually they've sent us some
incredible wine that we didn't have to
get off our ass to drink it was
wonderful and I am a wine drinker what
is happening right now I'm like the kind
of person that either buys the same type
of wine every single time or wake gives
me a new suggestion also brought to you
by tracker guys tired of losing your
keys your wallets your phone your
backpack to your belongings tracker
pixel makes it so you don't to worry
about that again it's a tiny their new
tiny coin size device the lightest
bluetooth tracking device out there and
its small enough to fit anywhere guys
tracker will make sure you don't lose
any of your belongings go to the tracker
that's th e TR AC kar comm slashed and
Julian get 20% off your first order
trust me awesome device and lastly
brought to you by lift guys lift
believes that ride a ride showing driver
was what
in retail yeah because every time I let
it go PT she hits the microphone with a
PG girl oh my god believes that the
ride-sharing drivers should be fun which
is why I notice have lift routes get a
perfect five star rating they're looking
for new drivers it's a great gig make
your own hours keep your own tips cash
out and sleep with Express pay and right
now you can get a $500 new driver bonus
when you go to lift calm that's ly
ft.com / Jenna Julian check it out thank
you sponsors thank you so much sponsors
well coming up with Genesis if you
couldn't tell already it'd be kind of a
little [ __ ] podcast what Kermit was
jealous I can't touch hermit I can no
longer touch him it's true I I had an
allergic reaction occurred I held it
first thing I hugged no seriously I
spent living with all the dogs and then
specifically I spent time with Kermit I
have my mic back young ladies detective
Pete we give you a blanket and a table
for one episode he's taking over the
whole thing please have my mic anyway
we're podcasting we're podcasting I held
Kermit I looked at my arm and I have
these hide I'm having them a little bit
now earlier I had these like little
hives and it's only Kermit it's not I
know
well you're not the first person that's
had that was specifically Kermit my
friend Kim like back in the day he in
Boston he like licked her arm one time
and she was like all that sweet thank
you I love kisses and then had like the
most horrible hives on her arm after
that like it's his mouth like he's a
komodo dragon his his saliva is poison
[Laughter]
[ __ ] extra today she really is peach
I swear to god she hits the mic again
and she doesn't care about you
oh no I specifically wanted to have
marbles on the podcast but then anywhere
marble goes the Aggies get jealous
little sheep because marble is going to
the dentist tomorrow morning at 7:00
a.m. which for those of you that have
dogs and have had to have like teeth
procedures oh my god she did pulling the
mic with her and it's like it's really
stressful and as marvellous gets older
and older it gets more and more
stressful for me because it's dangerous
for them as they age to go under
anesthesia so he had all his blood work
and stuff a while back they said it
should be good but I had a friend that
we keep running into at different events
she watches a lot of dogs and she was
like my friend's nine-year-old same age
as my 9 year old Chihuahua went under
and died during surgery so like it's
scary it's pretty scary so we're just
trying to make sure that he has a fun
enjoyable day today because tomorrow is
gonna suck he's been getting real
spoiled he got all the pets and
scratches more than you - yeah speaking
of which this he's done eating for today
yeah he's so we're taking him first
thing in the morning so he's got to be
fast this is just so wild guys enough
licking this is what happens every night
we go up to that and then this weird
three so happens it's pretty gross I
think we can feed him a little bit after
the podcast you wanna do dinner right
after yeah but he yeah he needs to be
fasted but um yeah it's really scary and
usually Kermit and marbles are like on
the same tooth schedule so like even the
last one they both went under together
but Kermit's teeth somehow like still
look really good for the most part like
that
yeah his remaining teeth look healthy
yeah but um marbles
it's his mouth is just so little in the
you know and the teeth crowding is just
so intense so everything just gets stuck
in his mouth and he refused to see dry
food he has for a long time so well this
is the best that we can do so he's
probably got about six teeth left
I can't imagine they're gonna take any
less than four out Marmol you don't mean
yeah he might have
humanity might be full-blown - he might
be full-blown toothless after tomorrow
so by the time you're watching this send
some happy thoughts over to marble and
hope that he's doing okay and then
everything goes well with his surgery
and while you're at it go ahead and send
Rome and snaggle some :
yeah and Colin and Bowie all of your
love and thoughts because they had an
absolute nightmare scenario I just I
feel so awful for him because she texted
me there in Australia right now it's
literally the first time that Bowie's
been to Australia and she texted me that
snaggle and monkey her two dogs snaggle
who they rescued and was abused in his
previous life was with a dog sitter and
she was also watching a medium-sized dog
who for some reason attack snaggle who's
like the sweetest goofiest little floppy
guy and uh he's he had to have his eye
removed and is gonna be in the hospital
until they get back they think anything
he's gonna be fine they said other than
they having to literally remove his eye
because of the the injuries he's okay
and like I can't imagine I mean that's
just like that's kind of unfathomable
being out of the country and getting the
call like wait what it's nightmare what
I don't yeah and I mean I don't know any
of the details I just feel horrible for
them I know it's like a really shitty
thing to have to go through nonetheless
when you're on them like the first
vacation you have taken as a family like
ever ever so yeah I mean San román
calling you love like I said snow has to
be okay
just it's one of those things yeah I
mean the closest thing we've ever had to
that happen was when we came home and
Kermit's tail was broken yeah but like
that didn't end up being a problem you
know they kindly asked me if I'd like to
amputate his tail to which I was like do
we have to but it's still it's
terrifying like not being there and then
you have to deal with your hurt an
injured dog like you know sad girl's
life is different now in Rome's life is
it's just really it's awful and for any
of those of you out there that have had
something like that happen when you're
not present
it's just really frustrating and like
just sucks man yeah so sad yeah that's
no good like I mean know whose fault
that is again like we don't know how
that happened it could mean no one's
fault it's like if if my mom was
watching the dogs and she takes them to
the dog park like one of them gets
attacked at a dog park you know or like
if if my mom for watching my mom's dog
and her dog gets out of the yard and
gets hit by a car you know it's just
sometimes it's nobody's fault sometimes
it's just like a terrible [ __ ] thing
that happens yeah it's just awful just
hug your babies guys hug you little
babies like you know have them next to
you and you know not to sound more but
but just like cherish every moment
that's why you guys sit down on the
table even though you little knowing
speech you take up a space of three
dollars why does she do that just draws
herself out I don't know oh my god she
just switched her body sat on Kermit and
so that she could hold your hand she
just wants to hold your hand so what
have we been doing today watching star
generation we check your casa
Universe jean-luc Picard Dana Wharf and
Troy dr. crusher Geordi LaForge Riker
starch I did nationai [ __ ] we're taking
a car so you never I'm grace well let me
tell you let me tell you how this
happened okay so I love Seth MacFarlane
with all of my heart all of it I love
you Julian but like half my hearts with
Seth just like half of your hearts with
Amy Poehler's fine okay
we haven't a mutual understanding good
it's all good
it's not even like a Hall Pass like I
don't I'm not even attracted to him
you know what it's okay you have the
Hall Pass you already got it thank you
argue for it anymore cuz we all [ __ ] I
was watching the Orville which was his
show on Fox right isn't that Fox cuz
family guys on Fox
could you stop scratching um you know he
must have some insanely insane contract
like he could never work on another
network other than Fox but so I was
watching the Orville because it's Seth
MacFarlane's new show which is like
sci-fi space
it's basically Star Trek 2017 Star Trek
but funny it's very searching and well
it's directly started yeah it's almost
like it's like Star Trek without calling
the names the same name it's calling it
the orbit and and instead of Worf it's
you know whatever was his name yet so I
was watching it and I was a little
skeptical as I imagine anyone would
because I grew up watching Star Trek The
Next Generation which is like to me that
is Star Trek you know if you grew up in
the 60s 70s the William Shatner version
is your Star Trek just like when you
were born or when I was born who ever
played Batman or Superman or spider-man
this is your Batman like for me it's Val
Kilmer is my bat in yeah and Christopher
Reeves is my Superman that was the first
person I cycle Keens my that in the
crisper because Michael Caine's your bad
knee yeah and Christopher Reeve was my
back my Superman too I watched all those
not even those little before me I stole
that well yeah I don't think another one
came out for a little while yeah until
they started deciding that they made
more money just redoing the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyways so my Star Trek was the
next generation and it was like a big
[ __ ] thing to watch like I watched it
in my dad's house always like we would
sit down and watch it and like you know
it's like the way that your parents
described Saturday Night Live when it's
like the world would [ __ ] stop
everyone's watching Saturday Night Live
that's what it felt like
although I imagine it wasn't but it felt
like everyone was sitting down to watch
Star Trek because it was the first time
that it had you know been on television
since the original version and it was
really exciting and I [ __ ] loved it
it was amazing and I feel like there's
part
like when they do the data episodes
where he's like learning how to be a
human and feeling human emotions and it
just like it makes you a better person
to watch Star Trek so it was really
excited about watching the orville and
as I turned it on of course a little
skeptical but had high hopes because I
love Seth MacFarlane more than anyone in
the whole wide world except for Julie
and Grandma Bob wasn't peach and I was
like this is so fantastic in the first
couple episodes I was like alright I get
it you know has the cheesy bits of Star
Trek like some of the funny stuff like
they're shooting like if you didn't
watch Star Trek him you watch the Orval
you'd be like this is kind of shitty
like kind of cheese you have to have
yeah exactly
and you're like alright the acting is a
little cheesy and you know what like you
you wouldn't appreciate what the show is
trying to do if you hadn't seen Star
Trek before but if if you went into it
with an open mind I feel like you and
you didn't watch Star Trek you'd be able
to appreciate it but by episode 3 when
they have an episode about the first
command or whatever who is in a
relationship with another male because
they're your host species is male and
they have a baby and it's female in the
whole episode is about what they're
gonna do that is Star Trek though like
they just had these episodes where
that's like nothing to do with space
travel an adventure it's all just like
this social it's beautiful I [ __ ]
love it and it's amazing so then I was
like I'm sold
I love the orville and then I realized
that Julian had never watched Star Trek
oh but you've seen the movies I've seen
a couple of the movies like Chris Pine
yeah Chris Pine yeah yeah what kind of
tree is that okay okay
it's a krysta yeah I've seen I think
only one of the newer yes I never ever
watched the show again and I feel like
this comes up a lot in the podcast I
didn't grow up watching TV it was just
not a lot of TV shows I watched we just
weren't allowed like we could like it
wasn't like there were no you know
monitors in the house or movies we
watched and [ __ ] I just there was
regular TV was not a part of my like
childhood yeah and so so many shows I
like never got into or understood or got
references from hazard has an adult now
and Star Trek is no exception like I
never ever watch Star Trek and I
personally you know I watched the Star
Wars movies and I know I was like I'm I
still am just like a very mild fan like
I like Star Wars I enjoy it I'm not a
huge hardcore fan I don't go to
comic-con
I don't follow every little fan theory
this and that I'm just not a huge fan
but I I never had any idea about Star
Trek and I personally just thought
because of my lack of knowledge was that
they were just kind of two of the same
thing it was like there were Star Wars
they were start shakin balls just like
space travel sci-fi ones this one's the
other I didn't realize what you could
just kind of explain now about Star Trek
that it deals a lot more with real-life
things and it kind of has a very very
different tone to it yeah it was a like
about making the world like a better
place through entertainment sci-fi yeah
I had zero idea that was that was Gene
Roddenberry trying to yeah which is
awesome and I am and like in watching
the Orval that's kind of what's
Bridgette the gat for yeah is that the
herbals easy easy to watch it's Seth
MacFarlane it's new it's like I can
watch that and then for me it's like now
now we're starting to watch Star Trek we
just finished one episode and we're
moving on I know and that's why last
night I tweeted the day that had like
data invented highlighter because I
forgot how beautifully glossy and
amazing his whole entire [ __ ] face
was okay he that man is glowing but I
can't wait til you get to the episodes
with data
oh my god [ __ ] lot okay once I start
watching more Star Trek we should do
some Star Trek podcast oh yeah so um I
also looked up because we love the show
face off which is all the special
effects makeup it's like a Project
Runway except special effects makeup if
you have not watched that show if Julian
loves that [ __ ] show you use the
snapchat people on there all the time
and the judges are so harsh on them like
they're so [ __ ] harsh what are their
names again Glenn Hetrick
Glenn Hetrick and uh the bald guy with
Susie he's legendary but they like how
it's a great like out diction each other
he's like it's a it's you know so they
show this special effect makeup of this
guy that supposed to look like a tree
and it's like you know to the untrained
eye I'm like and that guy looks like a
tree it's a little funny
whatever they did it in like a day
yeah and he's like it's devoid and
crippling and you're like oh my god dude
like go easy on a man what the [ __ ] yeah
they go in on those guys so anyways that
show the host is McKenzie Westmore who
is the daughter of Michael Westmore who
actually did all of the makeup and
special effects makeup on Star Wars
sorry Star Trek The Next Generation and
the subsequent series after like Deep
Space nine and stuff so it was really
cool to watch it and be like you know
data's highlight is on fleek but it's
also he did not invent it Michael
Westmore invented it yeah that's true
he is the mentor on face off he walks
through and we like to call ourselves
faceoff connoisseurs okay yeah we have
seen all of these I don't think we
finished the most current season but
other than that yes but even the most
current season was all stars wasn't it
yeah I think so I think [ __ ] to avoid in
crippling yeah the voiding crippling but
Michael Westmore invented the full face
highlighter challenge although someone
someone tweeted me a picture of the Tin
Man and I was like you know that's a
good point like I respect that point but
he is in silver paint it's not her it's
not exactly highlight you know yeah
because silver is like metallic so I
don't know if it counts yeah
Dana though Wolfe exactly it looks like
he's in black and white and the rest of
the characters are in color no Dana
looks like a glow he looks like that
picture of James Charles when his face
is completely white like he's blinding
okay hey sisters by the way like none of
that shade to James Charles I like James
he I think he's a really nice kid
and very talented but has anyone seen
that stuff I'm gonna hold on she's
looking at it's uh it's called James
Charles saying hi sisters but he's in
the ouija trailer it's a hallmark job
twenty-one seconds long you can't see
this but you can hear it that's too
close sorry yeah it's called James
Strauss saying hi sisters buddies in the
Ouija trailer it's only like 20 seconds
long
it's an incredible video their user name
is Jasmin fantastic so if you like Star
Trek so much how come you never dressed
up as a Star Trek character first you
know I feel like that doesn't need to
happen in order to like something I
personally think that you haven't quite
proved your Star Trek fandom until you
dress up as one of the characters I've
never dressed up as my elder scrolls
like I'm really excited for Julian to
watch Star Trek although Julian is like
you sit on your phone and watch no I
don't know I don't take that phone I
know what I'm watching I'm watching new
things okay I was I was literally doing
no it came out 1980 new for me you know
what I mean when I'm watching something
I haven't watched and it's not mindless
reality television I am watching
attentively mm-hmm the only thing I was
doing on my phone in there was looking
up what you were asking me to look up
which is why people don't like Wil
Wheaton and I was looking it up on my
phone forgot you like totally forgot
but I was like yeah there's some like
Internet II reason people don't like him
but I forget what it is it wasn't as
dramatic as I thought no I I don't need
to convince you I'm genuine I'm
genuinely into it like the whole time
sold you said it in a sold on Star Trek
she but you do keep saying I want you to
be a better person you should watch Star
Trek implying that I'm just like a bad
guy star trekkin no it just makes you a
better person cuz it does everybody
knows that duh we get you some [ __ ]
Star Trek in your life will you please I
want to know from
what are you calling Trekkies right
mm-hmm from the dink Trekkies what are
some there are any well uh there might
not be
and then someone feels an immense amount
of pressure I'm a Trekkie in order to
answer whatever in question feel the
pressure I want to know what there's got
to be some really cool podcast ideas
there with Star Trek either quizzing you
because you're supposedly know I forget
so much that's why I'm rewatching the
series with you watch it when I was a
child how old are you I don't know I
mean I don't think I started but like I
wasn't a toddler like I wasn't watching
it is like a baby but I was watching it
as like seven yeah you don't either like
I would like also mind you my dad would
let us watch you know my mom would let
us watch like Full House in the Simpsons
and my dad would let us watch like some
things that weren't necessarily for kids
but are fine for kids yeah like Star
Trek next generation is totally okay for
kids you know I mean kids is you know at
your discretion whatever age I'm not
saying it's good for all kids or
whatever
it's a any parents discretion obviously
but my dad was like yeah it's science
and like drama not violent it's like you
know it'll get in a fight scene but
classic Star Trek it's like some of its
kind of cheesy like you just saw this is
[ __ ] where they roll and they kick the
person over their head hell the [ __ ]
yeah like I'm here for that um not a lot
of blood not a lot of like sexual things
going on especially bite it's just like
a painting yeah it's like a green screen
well even like you watch stuff that's
put out for kids now and it's like it's
pretty intense especially a lot of kids
play video games where there's like gore
and violence and [ __ ] yeah bro why now
and asked if you would watch let your
kid watch Star Trek next generation I'd
be like hell yeah boy you want to sit
down and watch this and not play GTA 5
come with me come let's watch data and
his full face highlighter challenge be a
good person yeah I mean you can watch
Star Trek I don't think that's a crazy
thing to think that Star Trek came you
know but like we
I wasn't like a toddler but I was a
little bit older but I also wasn't a
teenager I mean I watched it how many
seasons are there of the next generation
I want to say at least seven I mean I
can look it up I think there might be
seven but then there was Deep Space nine
which we didn't like as much different
actors totally different whole new cast
pretty sure whole new cast it's like
when they remake a movie or a TV show
it's just like redone yeah so like if
they remade Seinfeld and it was called
like Seinfeld the next generation it
would obviously be different actors that
make sense which I tried to make Julian
watch all of Seinfeld but we only got to
like season three well you stopped to
you wanted to start watching us a
trailer that's true but I liked that I
also made the mistake of like starting
at season one like I really should have
started do it like season three because
it's not you they're not in like chronic
chronological order
yeah and then you but I feel like if you
know how good it is then you can go back
and watch some of the older ones and get
all the really cool jokes and [ __ ] but
like I understand that it's slow
sometimes to start a new series when
it's not like kick-ass from the
beginning although I think Seinfeld in
the beginning it takes patience for sure
I think it's good guy do you think it's
not about what I agree I just I only
stopped watching it cuz you know there
was other stuff to watch it's true like
the office over and over again whoa
take a chill pill have a glass of wine
Oh what did you just say glai me yeah
you just gonna try wink calm take the
quick palette profile quiz link will
recommend distinct and interesting wines
that actually customize actually I'm
talking to you to your palate profile
and then a wat a wine a box of wine
assorted wine flavors that are perfect
for you only will get delivered to your
door and you get to drink them
all right there's no time wasted the
store trying to figure out what wine
might be delicious it's going to be
delicious it's not a question and you
don't have to do the work okay
when base wing faces the winds they send
you on taste preference and they'll even
introduce you to new rare and custom
ones that you won't get anywhere else
which is awesome their selection is
incredible true right now try to so head
to try wink calm / annejulien look at
their selection - but they that you
basically just take the palette profile
quiz it's super easy give it a try and
see if you are a line drinker I think
you absolutely should try wink it's an
incredible service and they do it right
and you get to learn about all sorts of
new wines that you never would have
found this is so incredibly hard when
you do that peach gonna try wink calm /
Angelina get 20% off
sorry $20 off your first order and they
will cover the shipping for you you're
gonna like it also guys tracker is a
sponsor this week guys when you're
looking for your keys wallet and it's
making you late for things or you're
worried about bags with expensive
belongings in them just throw a tracker
pixel in them it's trackers
new-and-improved tiny little tracking
device bluetooth based and it's small
enough to fit anywhere on your keys your
on the back your phone in any bag and
any on your dog ends up my keys in my
backpack you it's it's so small but it
works so well okay and when you lose an
item that has a tracker pixel attached
you just use your smartphone and a 90
decibel alert will help you find it in
seconds it even has a light on it so you
can find it in the dark right now I have
my tracker pixel on my drone in my drone
bag in my camera bag we always talk
about it's in all of our stuff so we
don't lose it all right
and because tracker every tracker user
is part of the biggest crowd looking
Network in the world you can find your
lost item from miles and miles away
really awesome right now go to the
tracker that's th e TR ACK our comm
slash only get 20% off any order and
they have a 30-day money-back guarantee
so if you don't like it for whatever
reason you get your money back that's
how confident they are that their
product works and you will like it I can
vouch for it it's awesome peace of mind
is something that I'm willing to invest
into and tracker helps with that lastly
guys lyft is looking for new drivers and
lyft is an awesome ride sharing service
the best one out there they treat their
drivers right which is why like I said
nine out of ten lift rides get a perfect
5 star rating imagine being able to earn
$100 per week plus tips and not having
to wait weeks to get paid Express pay
lets you cash out instantly plus you get
tips drivers have been paid over 200
million dollars since tips were
introduced and and they were the first
it's awesome like tips like for a while
you felt like why am I
taking this ride and not tipping them
out you know lift is the way to do it
they tipped their drivers you treat them
right and they're looking they're
looking for new drivers guys so if you
need a part-time job or you need just a
little extra cash on the side you want
to make your own hours you don't have to
code at certain times or be at an office
and clock in and sit at a desk you're
driving and you're meeting people and
it's exciting they also make pickups a
real breeze they have color-coded amp
signs in the lift car so that your
customer knows exactly which lift you
are when you pull up to the location you
just snotted on my phone I'm sorry if
you don't like me joining the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating his people better at lyft calm
sky stone and Julian and score yourself
a 500 our new driver bonus highly
recommended if you're in need of work
thank you sponsor sponsors thank you
ding fam for putting up with the
sponsors so I looked it up there are
seven seasons of the next generation so
you guessed him yeah and um there's so
many [ __ ] movies like I didn't I
think I've seen one
Teresita list yeah sure look films the
motion picture 9 G Sonya the Wrath of
Khan a search for Spock the voyage home
the final frontier undiscovered country
that's generations first contact
insurrection nemesis star trek into
darkness and beyond I think I've seen
Star Trek I think I've seen the one who
called Star Trek that's the only movie
you saw
no I I mean I think that I've seen some
of the ones from the 90s but I have not
seen the newer ones so I've seen like
the older one other question yes are
they generations the next generation 7
seasons during those seasons were those
movies made and the same actors in it or
is it yeah so like jean-luc Picard is
this objective of generations yeah they
came out during so they were like
simultaneously filming yeah it was like
a [ __ ] deal but like when I said this
to Julian like every what we were
talking about but I said something about
like data or Geordi LaForge or like I
don't know who that is and like well you
don't know data is you don't know Geordi
LaForge is what is your life yeah how do
you live I live just fine where is like
I'm sure if you're your mom or my mom
found out that you didn't know who Spock
was they'd be like we need to fix this
we didn't know if you didn't know his
[ __ ] was yeah yeah well I'm I'm Debbie
don't worry I'm fixing the problem we're
watching Star Trek now I know who's Alma
whose pockets and the orbital in the
orbital by the way guys the orbital is a
[ __ ] great show
not sponsz if you if you are you are and
of like I don't know sci-fi space Star
Trek yeah but like even not Star Trek
even if you never watch Star Trek but
you like into that sort of thing with
some humor but also like some some more
than humor content like the Orville is
great like it's I blew away my
expectations I had low expectations yeah
I feel like it's filling that void
for me what Star Trek was it's very it's
like a nostalgic but it is new you know
I mean which is really exciting because
I don't think that I've watched like a
major network television show and so
[ __ ] long look on TV yeah like a CBS
Fox like a lunch basically guy
yeah survivor but like what's a new one
that you'd think of that you tuned into
like a new show yeah only only new
seasons of old shows right yeah no I
mean is there I can't think of one I
feel like sometimes those networks just
pump out whatever see what lands and the
profit Network
no that's like CNBC yeah yeah yeah I'm
talking about like Fox see yes like the
baby's a big fool yeah when every fall
they have new shows The Bachelor looked
like that's not a new show not a new
show well we didn't even watch this
season really you watched like one
episode the last season I wash yeah yeah
I don't know that's just like another
Testament yeah like the thing I'm
scripted no I know I know like like Blue
Bloods and like yeah I used to when I
used to work at Radio the radio station
I worked at I was in putting promos for
all those big show yeah so I was like
here are the names of them and they
would all sound so cheesy and all the
sound bites they used to cut the promise
was like oh my god like how is anyone
gonna watch this why am I putting this
on the radio to uncle's living together
under one roof with a baby Madam
President what's gonna happen yeah like
come on yeah that's I mean a lot of it's
in my opinion just a lot of the major
Network it shows that come out the
primetime shows there's just pure well
they recycle them and see what lands
then they cancel them then they but
they're catering they're catering to a
different audience than us I'm catering
to internet-savvy people are catering to
our parents true generally it's very
true no I think you're a which is why I
think the Orval is so cool because it
like it has there's like an ounce of
Family Guy because there's Seth
MacFarlane there's like good humor and
there's like unexpected but it's not
it's very rare it's few and far between
but it's also like it's an it's not
enough to compromise the tone that they
go for and in my opinion a chief like
there will be a moment where Seth
MacFarlane has a funny little quip where
you're like oh I didn't expect that it's
funny but then the scene ends properly
they don't ruin it with some like
grotesque like totally you know what I
mean it would be very easy to do that
and you you might go into the show
thinking oh [ __ ] they're gonna really
Family Guy it up or whatever but it's
not like that thing on its they preserve
what I think from what I know the Star
Trek kind of feeling is all about mm-hmm
which is what's what's cool about it I
think yeah and it also does feel a
little cheesy because I like that yeah
yeah I mean most of the I feel like most
of the new shows that I watch are like
digital ya know it's like they don't
have they don't have high budgets some
of it just feels really fake to me
yeah like I'd rather watch out on
whatever it I agree but if you'd like to
watch next generation or anything
Star Trek related a lot of them are on
Netflix like every single season of the
next generation is on Netflix so the
orbital Cirque the Orval is on Hulu
which can we talk about for one second
because someone [ __ ] tweeted at me
and I agree so much I like
I don't want anyone to know but I
sometimes really prefer Hulu to Netflix
and I like I like what they have on
there was a new update I'm so angry if
you have Hulu and you know what they did
to that [ __ ] the mobile update can you
please don't yeah you are in the same
boat as me what the [ __ ] have they done
to this bug in air it was an entirely it
was an overhaul of the platform not just
a mobile app I don't like it but this
isn't it's also not me being like I
don't like change like every time they
change a YouTube a little bit people are
like this is [ __ ] dumb you know like
they changed it so much it's
unrecognizable
I think the branding is different you
should just be this green Hulu now it's
all this like blue to purple disease
it's a sight crop it's a platform why
overhaul yeah thing is the same they
rebranded the logo the look the way the
app function is just really hard to find
anything without searching for it yeah I
don't know I mean I'm not I I don't hate
the app ism as much as so many people
have told me that they hate the app
because I've seen a lot of like anger
towards the new app I don't really quite
get it because I mean it's yeah maybe
it's not super intuitive the layout but
I don't mind the gradient I like the new
colors that's fine I just wished it like
on the homepage like you know when you
used to open the Hulu app it would have
like here the shows that you're
currently watching here are some shows
that you might like here are new
releases now when you open it it's just
like the poster of whatever they're
currently promoting yes and then you
there's like a browse it just makes oh
sit you can't find anything unless you
spent like physically type it in they
definitely made it more catered to what
they want you to look at yeah which i
think is done which is annoying it
doesn't selection honest here all of the
[ __ ] like streaming site apps and
even network TV apps to the chromecast
[ __ ] and streaming onto your TV are all
garbage I mean you go like for instance
if we were to go on the Food Network app
and and and I'm sure you read remember
agent Allman and Guy Fieri all night
we click say we click on an episode of
the Triple D right we play it I leave
the app because I'm not gonna just sit
on that [ __ ] app it's streaming on my
TV you know I don't need to be in the
app
I go on Twitter I go on something else
oh hold on I gotta run to the bathroom I
gotta pause the app I got a positive
show I go back into the app it's not
connected the thing anymore I have to
reconnect oh and then it's just
recommending all the shows you think
about show me what I've been watching
and things like that don't just I'm
already here in the app trying to stream
something right and this is already the
future right I'm right sending magic
information from my phone over the air
into my TV yeah no cords that's amazing
why do you have to why do you have to
hold it up with all this stupid tech
inside that app that doesn't function
right it can't run in the background I
don't get that TV show who who wants to
not be able to click pause you have to
go into the I mean that's maybe it's an
iOS thing or an era or a [ __ ]
operating system thing with mobile I
don't get it
I personally think it's like such a
brilliant thing like streaming things to
your TV and then it's also so broken can
I show it on the lifetime at first okay
yeah sure so like I like Hulu and I like
necks like slap because you don't have
to watch commercials although on Hulu
sometimes you do like currently you
don't you pay yeah but you remember
there was a time on Hulu and it was like
so frustrating you're like why am i
paying for an app that I also have to
watch commercials on yeah so I also have
downloaded a lot like I have discovery
or like ID or like the lifetime apps
sci-fi app who Newark yeah most food
network most of it is because I like one
show or one or two shows on that channel
and it won't be on Hulu or Netflix so
I'd like to watch it yeah and we do have
cable we still do pay for cables so if
you just download the app and then type
in your provider then you can watch it
like on-demand through the app which is
fine but like in some of them like the
lifetime app and I'm pretty sure the
discovery app too because we watched
that um Unabomber show right um through
this which is it show it's a good show
except for the last couple episodes when
they really they really just man they
needed to wrap it up so they just did it
real quick um but other than that it was
a great show in the lifetime app say you
know we were watching some of it like I
like to watch a lot of Project Runway on
an airplane
so I'll get through like half way and
then we're landing where I like fell
asleep and then I'm back in the hotel
room and I now I want to watch it on an
app or like I come home and I'm like I
want to stream it to my TV because I'm
home so I want to pick up where I left
off because the lifetime app not only
like does not honor that you already
paid for cable you need to watch
commercials in the app okay fine [ __ ]
so you're trying to fast-forward to the
part that you left off on you're like
I'm probably 3/4 of the way through
right you're just at the good part of
Project Runway they're about to hit the
[ __ ] runway okay you you you drag the
little dot 3/4 of the way down and then
it recognizes a possible to land on the
right spot right yeah but that's not
even the worst it's like all up slow
down there for a second there's like
four commercial breaks that you just
skipped so then it starts playing you
for commercials in a row right like or
four breaks long which is probably
seventeen commercials so you sit there
and you watch it and you're like all
right after this it's gonna go to my
spot
then it buffers for like 20 [ __ ]
minutes and then it goes back to the
[ __ ] beginning of the episode and
you're like why can't I just [ __ ]
watch this from one spot okay I'll watch
15 commercials if you need me to but
please for the love of God don't make me
restart every episode when I can't
finish it what the [ __ ] is this and they
blast those commercials so loud they
like commercials are at a really high
level there's been a significantly
higher than the plan when I'm in bed and
Julian falls asleep but I'm still
watching like I think we've said this
yeah and it's like I'm like I swear yeah
sorry so blame the attention but it all
circles back I mean this this all kind
of circles back to this like confusing
really great but also really shitty type
of app which is the streaming service
app that whether it's a channel or a
network or its actual service itself the
abbé sucks yeah you know it's a great
product hulu netflix so like at least
you can still use
ethics in my opinion like they run a
little smoother like if we're watching
house of cards and we have to pause it's
a lot easier to go into that and boskie
and on your phone yeah but I'm talking
about the streaming app on your phone I
read an article about somebody just
taking an absolute dump all over Apple
just as a whole and they were talking
about how you when you download things
from the iTunes Store which a lot of us
are already paying for one or multiple
streaming services or cable yeah you
know if you're like us we have like we
have a lot of stuff we pay for a lot of
stuff to watch you don't mean between
cable and to streaming yeah things like
you know we have more than most whereas
maybe one person has one streaming
service and a basic cable or yes but if
you want to like when you travel if you
want to download things from the iTunes
Store you can't broadcast it to you
television you have to watch it in your
app in the TV up yeah so buy so buying
and renting things locally from the
iTunes Store on your phone cannot be
streamed to a chromecast or Amazon
unless you have like an Apple TV can you
do it through now that's it they're
trying to push Apple TVs because
otherwise you can't do which is so I'm
trying to make Apple TV work a lot of
people love it i I get rid of coming
from but at the same time it's just it's
like Apple is all about user experience
right and into intuition in the
operating system making everything very
intuitive and easy and plain and simple
anyone can operate your grandma can use
an iPhone that's the whole idea right so
why not just go that one step further
and make it so you're already paying
money for this program you're renting it
you're buying you're doing something
you're not gonna I mean there's like
probably point zero zero five percent of
people are torrenting Shin putting it on
their iPhone like we're all pretty much
buying your [ __ ] right off the iTunes
store just let us stream it onto our TV
right don't make a spy on Apple TV it's
such a big overall I don't want to buy
an Apple TV everyone who has one is like
buying out to be I don't want to buy one
yeah I don't wanna have to set another
thing up like we have the chromecast
that's fine it's perfect why we have to
have a fire stick that's fine yeah
slightly less fun but still fun but
still like I didn't think about that
until like again I feel like I'm getting
taken advantage of sometimes because I
bought this currency
a Project Runway on my iPad so that I
could watch it when I was traveling but
then I also if I'm at home I had to open
up the lifetime app and watch ads on it
or I can sit on my beautiful couch with
my beautiful television and watch it on
my iPad [ __ ] yeah those are my choices
watch 15 ads in a row or watch it on my
iPad well what what has happened now
what has happened now is to counteract
that kind of stupid stupid like red tape
in an app sites like Netflix and I don't
know if really those but slightly sites
like Netflix now allow you to download
stuff for offline viewing YouTube does
it - yeah you can download is it only
YouTube red I think it'll need to read
it might be only Netflix if you have
another account you can now go into a
show and download episodes onto your
phone for offline news which is
literally all I do for plane rides now I
don't or I you know I buy something in
the iTunes Store but I would much rather
like just be able to download it I think
that's what Netflix is doing to kind of
counteract that problem yeah fix that
problem rather anyway it is so
frustrating don't like me I'm gonna have
an allergic reaction it's just
frustrating that like the cable
companies nickel-and-dime us and now the
streaming companies there's they're
finding a way to nickel and dime yes
even if you're a cord cutter like you're
you're consider as almost cord cutters I
mean work order I mean we so we don't
watch live television that's that's what
I mean get rid of our cable I know we
still kind of pay for it but we're not
paying for something we don't use
because we do use that login for all
these apps we're talking about yeah I
mean I still watch cable television
shows even cord cutters can watch those
though they just stream them right is
that is that at the point of being a
court are you like don't have cable just
cable yeah yeah I don't know I'm so hot
yeah these these lights are these let's
have like Suns in here we have two suns
in this time I think we need new lights
look at the docks look you can tell
artists I have their behave
yes on puddle puddle anyway guys
hopefully you enjoyed listening as rant
about things that aren't annoying to us
about streaming let me know if you
excited for Julie to watch Star Trek cuz
I am why if you want to send us ideas
about what things you could use Star
Trek relate on the podcast let us know
Jenna Julianne pot on Twitter if you
want our tweet us suggestions we've got
a feed this little BB boy before he
needs to fast we'll be back next week
after Marvel's has his teeth removed and
we're gonna be in Kentucky this weekend
mm-hmm excited yeah the University of
Kentucky Jay's gonna I'll see you there
something is keep your expectations
incredibly low but I'll see you I'll be
there tip and Ron will be there too oh
but no Doc's will be there no it does
we're gonna have to download some
Netflix videos for offline viewing for
that plane right [ __ ] it in anyway
hope you guys have a great week love you
see you later and probably on Twitch
like every night this week
[Music]
you